ladies and gentlemen
the ship has reached the shore
an emotional moment as the United
Nations treaty to protect the high seas
is finally agreed
delegates at the UN headquarters in New
York had worked through the night to
push a deal over the line after more
than a decade of failed talks a hugely
significant milestone
this treaty that will lay the groundwork
for creating
30 percent of the ocean into Marine
sanctuaries
that cannot be fished in
is so important all oceans and the
biodiversity within them are critical to
keeping the Earth in Balance generating
nearly half the planet's oxygen
absorbing a quarter of its carbon
dioxide and much of the excess heat it
generates
nearly two-thirds of the planet's oceans
are actually considered to be
international waters outside of the
control of individual Nations which
means all countries have a right to
explore research and fish there up until
now only one percent of these Waters
have been protected but the new UN
treaty promises to put 30 percent into
Marine protected areas by the end of
2030 a Target known as 30 by 30. this
will help to control things like fishing
deep sea mining shipping and the fair
sharing of profitable resources a key
sticking point during the negotiations
experts are warning though there's still
a lot of work to do
we've got to make sure that it's
implemented consistently so when it's
written on paper and agreed on paper
that that's what happens at Sea we've
got to again join all this up and make
sure that those other management bodies
that are managing shipping deep sea
Mining and official is adhere to to
what's said in in the the high seas
treaty multilateral agreements involving
nearly 200 nations are rarely perfect
but many view them as the only way to
make Global progress on climate change a
crisis that knows no borders in this way
the UN treaty is a major step forward in
protecting a fragile ecosystem that
helps to sustain life on Earth
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News